there's almost a part of me that wants
you to try playing drums again why
because I just he wants to start a man
yeah we're gonna get the band back
together I mean we can do it if you like
basic beats I can teach you yeah I feel
like honestly like you know you say that
you don't have like the concept of like
Rhythm and stuff like that but I feel
that's something that can be trained I
feel it's like you know when it comes to
like musicality and stuff yeah well when
it comes to like musicality right and
like you know playing like an actual
instrument yeah um you know there's like
people who are just like I can't [__]
like I cannot imagine you playing
I'm gonna it's gonna sound bad an actual
musical instrument
whoa what are you saying about drums
good you know the joke of what do you
call a guy who hangs out with a bunch of
musicians no the drama oh
because because like I feel percussion
is like hey look hey I play drums it's
fine
um I feel like it's something that can
be trained because I think just like
knowing can we teach a monkey to cook
we can make it put together a carbonara
but it might not taste good yeah it's
still the skill though right like I'm
not expecting you to be the [__]
greatest drummer in the world but I
reckon when it comes to like simple you
know different stuff like a four four or
three four like you could easily do that
if I enjoyed it it would be easy but if
I don't enjoy it I suck at stuff like
this because it's like I just have no
motivation to get better at it yeah
right
um I mean it's unfortunate yeah it is
normally like that what's what's like a
one skill you want to be able to like
absolutely Master by the time you're
like I'm too old to learn anything new
I don't think there's anything I can't
I'm getting older I guess that I would
want to learn I mean yeah I'd like to be
good at cooking
that feels like an OP Strat
in general no no everything has to get
you rizz Joey good I'm not doing it
unless I get rich
we already have Partners Joey you have
nothing to prove I'm passionate about
eating food yeah and I think I would
equally be passionate about making it if
I had the time and just the space to do
I just don't have time right now and
also I don't wanted that's not something
I'm interested in right now but I can
see myself being interested in it in
like 10 20 years right right when do you
okay I guess I guess since we don't have
time right now which I guess is like the
biggest factor for me learning any new
skill as well as it is for every working
adult wouldn't you guys think you're
gonna retire
when I have enough money
I mean we've seen we've seen we've seen
us like a slow Trend now about like a
lot of like well-off YouTubers who have
I guess announced their retirement like
you know PewDiePie I guess is like the
biggest he's also a dad now though he's
also a dad he also made crazy bank
that must be real Batman and his son are
set for life yeah let's be real exactly
and uh like I know there was a few
others as well that announced that was
the TV or something announced that he
retired as well he also yeah basically
he basically just made crazy Bank in
retirement how much crazy bank I make
see I think for me it's not only about
like do I have enough money uh to be
able to not work for the rest of my life
or you know be able to support my
children if I have any whatever but it's
more so for me it's like you know
because I feel like retirement is that
kind of point where you're like there's
nothing I want to like turn into a
career there's nothing I want to do that
will necessarily generate money anymore
yeah and feel for me it's like that's a
really important part about it because
it's like you can say you're retiring
right yeah you know say like oh I've
I've made enough money to support myself
for the rest of my lifetime and I've
been able to achieve this this and this
and I'm ready to put it to rest and just
like relax for the rest of my life but
if I retire and I get to the point where
I'm like yeah but there's still [__] I
want to do yeah then would you even
consider that retirement I mean I think
like you're it's not so much you're
going into retirement you're just
retiring one thing to start another
thing I mean for me I'm the kind of
person who I just need to be doing
something yeah so I I need to be doing
something you know like luckily enough
I'm in a position where I am comfortable
you know financially to be stable which
it's I guess what I thought I'd spend my
entire life working towards and like you
know Lucky in a position where I'm lucky
that I'm like okay I am stable and my
parents are stable and my family's
stable
um so I'm like if I were to like when I
reach retirement age whenever that age
is I still think I'd be doing something
yeah you know I saw like right now it's
all about oh didn't you you know right
now right now it's all about okay
everything I do needs to like have like
you know it needs to be needs to give me
longevity to hopefully set the way for
the future so so I am stable 10 20 years
from now so there's still like a part of
my mind where everything I do needs to
build towards a foundation yes
retirement to me means that Foundation
is set I do not need to worry and I can
focus on doing [__] that does not mean
anything in the grand Escape yeah
because like for example like my dad
went into retirement this year a few
months ago and I was like oh congrats
dad you know you finally retired you can
you know get out of this whole it sales
thing he's been doing for 30 plus years
of his life yeah and I was like so what
are you gonna do like like what's your
what's your retirement plan and he dead
ass just looks at me and he's like I
want to drive a bus
and I'm like Dad you and that's not
retirement you're just changing jobs at
that point like why like because I think
in his mind it was like it's not so much
like oh I'm still in the workforce or
like I'm going back to work it's just
something for him to do during the week
yeah yeah but I feel you know it's still
technically a job right being a bus
driver even if it may not necessarily be
a nine to five yeah five days a week
type of job it's still something you're
obligated to go and do and you get money
to do it right so I'm like I almost
don't count that as Retirement I I just
count that as like I think retirement
for me is when it's like okay the things
I'm going to do after all of my actual
obligatory works well that's been like
the burden of having to provide is kind
of gone yeah it's like and how you spend
your time doesn't necessarily generate
money or there's no like obligation to
to do it like you know like I'm sure
like you know I'll still be making like
YouTube videos just like casually after
I like Joey as a grander retire right
like you know maybe maybe that will
never stop who knows like I could be in
my 80s and I'll still be like you know I
still really want to make this video who
knows we don't know because YouTube
hasn't gone yeah I'd like to get to my
arc where like my like I just I have a
YouTube channel where all I do is like
right boys I gotta fix the toilet yeah
I'm thinking about remodeling this room
basically basically it's basically the
content that like Felix has been doing
as of late you know to like listening to
do a video where you like install the TV
yeah like to him he's made his money
he's good right but he's still making
those videos not because he's like I
need to put up this video to make money
to feed my family it's more so just like
I just want to do it regardless of what
it does right that's the stage I want to
read yeah I don't give a [__] what I
need to post stage yeah yeah I mean I'm
already at that point but
but it's like for me retirement is just
like it's a combination of like do I
have enough money where everything I do
after this point may not necessarily
generate any amount of money whatsoever
but I'll still do it yeah or is it like
to the point of like there is still
something I want to do that I can turn
into this big Financial thing that will
like still support me and still be
bringing in money right and it's like
it's I feel there's like no age for that
it's just kind of at the point where you
have to just kind of self-reflect and
being like all right am I there yet like
is there have I done everything I want
to do do I have enough money in the bank
you know is My Life Stadium happy to
welcome you know my inevitable death
like when when all of the stars have
lined up that's when I feel I can be
like all right you know what I'm
comfortable to retire now are you you
say retirement is just the point where
you can just pursue all of the hobbies
that you'd wanted to be retirement is
just like end credit games like that's
you know it's like it's like post game
it's post game that's all retirement is
it's just like I can keep doing my [__]
but I know at the end of the day I've
already got to the credits like there's
no obligation give me a new game plus I
want a new game plus let me start it
that's called reincarnation actually is
something I look forward to but I also
equally feel bad that I think like I
know it doesn't matter I don't know it
doesn't matter but it doesn't have like
you know it's not my life whatever but
you feel bad that a lot of like where
most people are at right now they can't
even like consider retirement levels of
saving for it and I you know because I
think we get excited and we're like yeah
what are we gonna do with when we retire
and do what we're gonna do it and I feel
bad when I'm like when you hear about
people who are like man I gotta work two
jobs the thought of retiring is not even
an option right I can't I can't ever do
[__]
um and I hope that whatever happens in
the world that it gets easier for people
to be able to consider retiring and do
it because the age of retirement is
rising in every country it is it is God
especially Japan holy [__] yeah I mean
what the [__] can you can you like if
you are somebody who joins the workforce
in like the like this this like decade
can you even like consider retiring like
can you even like can you genuinely get
to the end of your career and be like ah
yes I can live off the the retirement
money like I don't think most people can
even do that now like I think that's and
also I mean you'd have to be like I'd
say like living a pretty Frugal
retirement at that stage right like
because you're only so limited to what
yeah most people can't live off yeah
like most people yeah like you know like
Japan and like America with like 401ks
and [__] like in pensions in Japan and
[__] like you know they give you options
to be able to like save up for that
retirement but you know maybe you'd be
in a position where your job isn't
paying you enough or the lifestyle
you're living is like cutting into your
uh you know you're spending too much and
stuff like that that to the point where
it just makes it more difficult to
welcome that stage right and a lot of
people don't even make it to the
retirement age yeah Japan they do yeah
I'm very good at making them uh I'm
making it to retirement age
it's getting close to 70 in some
European countries and it's like don't
make it to 70. and even if they do like
you know maybe they have a few years in
life and it's like what is the what even
is retirement anymore like is retirement
even going to be a concept that is like
afforded to everyone or is it going to
be yeah something that only rich people
can can think about it I mean it should
be rewarded to everyone you know to be
honest but yeah just some countries it
makes it difficult